I think most of you all are very
familiar with our last keynote speaker
he's one of the Trailblazer of the world
of data science and open-source software
as a as the founder of our studio and
the creator of our studio IDE he has had
a profound impact on data analysis and
software development his work extends to
the development of our markdown shiny
packages and my favorite Bridging the
Gap between our Python and tensor FL so
today he here to share his insights on
the exciting quto project that is a
Jupiter based scientific and Technical
publishing system that's set to transer
how transform how we share knowledge so
without any further Ado with a warm
Round of Applause please welcome our
last keynote speaker of P data NYC
2023 JJ
aair thank you very much it's really
really exciting to be here uh and I'm
here to tell you today about something
new actually U something I'm going to
tell you about today we're announcing
today so that's kind of fun always fun
to do too at a conference um and by by
way of a little bit of introduction
actually most of this has been taken
care of um I'm the founder and CEO of
posit which you probably have never
heard of um but you have likely heard of
our studio which is kind of um we re we
renamed our studio posit last summer and
the reason we did that is that we wanted
to take the things we we had had a lot
of success working in the r ecosystem
but we wanted to do a lot of the things
we had done in R and do them much more
broadly to to affect to do work that
affected all data scientists and all
scientists and so we wanted to become a
multi- language data science tools
company um and we are early in that
Journey I'm going to share with you
today a bunch of the work that we've
done in the Jupiter and python ecosystem
but we're going to be doing a lot more
of it in the
future and I'll talk a little bit about
that today I'm going to give you a brief
orientation to what Cordo is because you
likely haven't seen or heard of of Cordo
either then I'm going to spend larger
part of the talk uh telling you about
CTO dashboards and then just a little
bit of a uh of a footnote about kind of
our the nature of posit as a company and
how we're approaching
python so let's start with learning a
little bit about what Cordo is um and
Cordo is is a is an open- source techn
publishing system you can think of it as
sort of taking Jupiter notebooks
converting them to markdown and then
processing that markdown into lots and
lots and lots of different types of uh
output formats and artifacts obviously
there are tools that do this like NB
convert uh already but Porto sort of
takes that to a whole another level um
it supports not just the kind of
conventional output formats like Word
documents and PDFs and web pages and
PowerPoint presentations things like
that but but also specialized project
types that let you build entire websites
or books or blogs um all from uh
computations in Jupiter so the real big
idea behind CTO is to sort of take the
work that you do in Jupiter and in
notebooks and then re reproducibly
transform it into various types of
production output so again Jupiter's is
where the computations happen markdown
is based on another open source project
called Pand which is a very very
powerful kind of scientific markdown
uh academic and scientific markdown that
supports lots of advanced features like
citations and cross references and
things like that uh and again turn it
into lots of different types of
outputs so just some really simple
examples to give you the basic idea the
first example I'm going to show you will
be nothing novel or noteworthy it's it's
there's a notebook here and we're going
to turn that into a web page there's no
options this is all just default
Behavior so I call I say quo turn this
into a web page and it makes a web page
that looks largely largely like the
notebook but um Cordo has a huge number
of options for how things are
transformed from notebooks into various
output formats uh and for some formats
like HTML and PDF it has like over a 100
different options so lots of ways to
tailor things so as a simple example of
that I'm going to change the theme and
the Highlight style and I'm going to add
like an ability for users to make
comments using hypothesis so I've added
those options at the top of the notebook
and then when I render it you can see
the theme and highlighting are indeed
different and then over here on the
right you can see this like commenting
bar that's just an example again there's
lots and lots of things you can do with
with options another example of this is
uh we have some options that let you
show and hide code so we're saying like
fold the code don't show it by default
but but provide the user tools to be
able to show the code if they want and
then we have those so those are document
level options and then we have cell
level options which are done with this
Hash Pipe special comment here we're
saying we want to make this a cross
referenceable figure so when I render
this you can see it looks a little
different now the code is hidden uh you
can see the cross reference here uh and
then there's a Code menu in the top
right and so then when I click on that
you know I have a way to toggle the code
so this is just by way of example
there's lots of other things you can do
but I just want to get you the basic
mental model of I have a notebook I add
options to it I specify different
formats ad options to the cells and that
tailor the type of of production output
that I can get so here's an example
another example of making a PDF in this
case we're going to say we want
citations to go in the margin uh we're
also going to say with PDFs like the
ideal reading width does not usually use
the full width of the page so we're
going to have a column that's a little
bit narrower but that means we have
space in the margin we can use the
putting the citations in the margin is a
good thing to do but also I've got two
side by-side figures and I want those to
use up more space so you can see in this
PDF I've got the the citation here and
I've used I've kind of flowed over the
margin with the side by-side figures so
again that's just an example of
rendering a PDF and this there's similar
sorts of options for lots of other
formats uh and then finally this is kind
of the final basic kind of quto 101
example is making a slide Deck with a
notebook here you can see i' I've
specified a different format revealed JS
um and I've provided a couple options
the logo and and a slide numbering
treatment um this presentation I'm doing
now is actually done with bordo and
reveal.js there's a lot of very fancy
things you can do with your
presentations uh here I'll just show a
simple example of a slide that has you
know a couple of side by-side plots on
it and you can see the logo is here and
the numbering is here so those are just
simple examples to give you the mental
model of taking notebooks and then using
options to customize their output and
rendering them out to l lot of different
lots of different formats um
so again briefly just to understand all
the mechanics what's the basic workflow
in quto you you it's a command line tool
and when you have a notebook you say
render the notebook and by default it'll
just render to whatever format that note
that notebook declares as its native
format but you can also vary that and
say well I actually want to I want to
render to a different format um I'll
talk about this in a minute but we
actually have another variet of notebook
which is a plain textt notebook and some
some users prefer to like work with
their notebook in a in a regular text
editor have it be uh readily diable in
Version Control so we have a plain text
version of notebooks it's still using
Jupiter it's still cells it's all the
same kind of backend but it's but it's
plain text um and so you can render
equally render the plain text uh
versions of documents here this is a has
a qmd file extension for quter mark down
um so that's how you render and then
there's a live prev server so if you if
you are going to work iteratively on a
notebook or a qmd and you want to have
it update every time you save you can
say Pho preview uh and in that case
you'll get you know here's Jupiter you
can see I'm running Pho preview down
here in a terminal and every time I save
the notebook then the output will will
update in
turn uh and I just want to briefly sort
of show you this plain text notebook
idea again people some people like this
because of it sort of works with any
text editor uh there's kind of
deterministic run order of cells
integrates with Version Control so you
know I think there's there's different
use cases for uh traditional notebooks
versus plain text quter supports both of
them uh just to walk you through this a
little bit this is kind of the the uh
markdown cell at the top that provides
all the options this is literally a code
cell the same thing as a code cell
inside a Jupiter notebook you can see
there it's got a a cell option on it
this is a markdown cell uh and this is
another coded cell so just really the
same thing as what we saw in the
notebook but just expressed in plain
text uh and then kind of the way
rendering works it's kind of the way
you'd expect if you're rendering a
Jupiter notebook we're not going to ex
we're not going to reexecute The
Notebook we assume that you have
executed all the cells in the way you
want in the order that you want to the
specifications you want and then when we
render we're just going to take the
Jupiter notebook turn it into markdown
feed it through and and create output
whereas if you're using the plain text
workflow we're actually going to turn
that qmd into a jupyter notebook and
actually execute all the cells uh and
then render the final output you can uh
choose to if you want when you're using
a regular notebook you can have it
reexecute it every time um if you want
but by default it does not execute and
there's various ways to do caching of
outputs so that if you know you can use
Jupiter cash so that if you're just like
working on content and you're not
updating your computations that you
don't pay for rerunning all the cells
all the
time okay so that's the basics of CTO
just how it works what it is uh but what
I'm really here to talk about today is a
new output format that we're actually
announcing today uh called CTO
dashboards and the idea here is to
easily create dashboards from Jupiter
notebooks um and these dashboards could
be could be static sort of produced you
know one time and produce on a schedule
or they could be interactive and have
like a backend server behind them I'll
show you both of them those variations
so just to give you an some examples
these are just some some dashboards that
we created with Cordo dashboards are
generally like split into rows and
columns you can kind of divide up your
rows and columns however you want um
here you can see there's pages so you
can have multiple pages in a dashboard
these are value boxes which are things
for sort of good you know top level
values so that's one example I'll show
you five or six examples just to give
you a flavor of the sort of dashboards
you might create and then I'll get more
into the mechanics of how you actually
uh create them so that's one here's
another one that similarly looks a
little different similarly has multiple
Pages uh it has also value boxes and
this one is has a tab set so the author
of this dashboard really wants to focus
your attention on this visualization and
then if you want to drill into more
detail you have a chance to use the tabs
to do that
um here's another dashboard that's
similar has value boxes and pages this
one has a sidebar which is often used
like for inputs in an interactive
dashboard uh or it could be used for
sort of explanatory or peripheral data
that the user might want to optionally
hide um here's another pretty simple
dashboard this one doesn't have multiple
Pages this is an example of of a
dashboard you might want to rerun on a
scheduled basis so you probably want to
you probably want to update this
dashboard like once an hour um you know
and I think if you think about sort of
um deploying things if you have a
dashboard like this and you have maybe
like hundreds or thousands of people
that might be hitting it you really
don't want to rerun all this python code
every single time someone hits the
dashboard what you want to do is say
well the data is not going to change but
once an hour or whatever once a day or
whatever it is so we'll just re render
it once on a schedule and then people
can just access static static
HTML um here's an example of uh a
dashboard that's built that around a
deployed model so it kind of starts off
with the model card and then it has some
basic information on model performance
drift M classifi results so um this
another another use case um and this
also shows that it's pretty easy to have
dashboards that incorporate a lot of
narrative and content um they're not
just strictly just like oh look here's
like nine plots with no context it's
very easy to bring in markdown and bring
in links and uh Rich
explanations um and then here is an
example of a interactive dashboard this
this dashboard actually has a python
process running behind it and when you
uh change these check boxes or um or you
know this distribution widget it's going
to render the plots and then re and and
update the filtered view of the data so
this is different the other dashboards I
just showed you don't have a python
process behind them this one does and
I'll you
a little bit get into like how how
exactly that works and how we do
that and finally um this is a really
simple dashboard probably a little bit
simpler than the other ones uh this is
using plotly and so one of the things
that this illustrates a little bit is
that you know plotly has a bunch of
interactive features here it has this
timeline that those interactive features
are still available even even in a
static uh dashboard because everything's
done on the client this dashboard
essentially has two pages indicators and
data um it has two
rows uh and it splits the second row
into two columns so I'm showing you this
last because I'm going to walk you
through exactly how we can take a
notebook and turn it into this dashboard
so kind of take a look at this remember
what it looks like and I'll show you
kind of what the authoring looks like um
so here's our our notebook um and you
can see that it has the the the What's
called the front matter here the options
and we've said we want to have a
dashboard as our format that format
could on the other hand you know doc X
or reveal JS here it's a dashboard and
you remember we had an indicators page
so in my notebook I create a level one
heading called indicators and that
creates a page in the dashboard um and
then I you recall the first row was this
big wide visualization so I create a row
here and I put my uh I put my
visualization in it and now I need to
create my second row that has the other
two plots and so if I if I scroll down
in the notebook I have another row and I
have my other two plots so that's the
notebook that's going to kind of feed
this dashboard when I quto render this
or quto preview this I get the the
dashboard that we just saw and you can
see that things are organized into rows
and columns as specified by those by
those headings um if we look down to the
next page remember we had an indicators
page and we had a data page if I keep
scrolling down in the notebook you can
see I have data uh I have a markdown
cell here that just has a link and a
little logo and then I'm using it tables
package to make a table and then when I
when that is rendered in the dashboard
um you can see the data page is provided
here and you get a version of the table
that works well on the dashboard and get
the mark down so that is the basic
mechanic there's quite a bit of
additional things you can do which I'll
show you but that's kind of the basic
the way things work you have notebooks
that have cells that have output you
have markdown cells you have headings
that give you the structure
um so yeah this is actually you've kind
of seen all of this uh you have a
navigation bar and Pages you have the
things that perform layout like tab sets
rows columns and sidebars and then you
have the data uh and those are cards and
typically you can think your mental
model is like a cell in a Jupiter
notebook maps to a card which presents
some data and that data can be of all
different types it can kind of be
anything that you can that you can
render from a Jupiter notebook you know
as it turns out you know plots and
tables are really popular value boxes
also and and content but you can
anything Maps any any sort of thing even
just like the results of of a of a
summary of data or statistical model or
something like
that uh so I want to underscore that all
of the components that I'm showing you
here can be authored and customized
either within the notebook UI which I in
kind of my big demo initial demo I
showed you using a notebook or you can
also use the plain text q&b workflow I'm
going to go through some of these in
detail and in this in sort of
enumerating them I'm going to use the
plain text uh version because it's a
little easier for me to show you all the
structure it kind of fits more compactly
but just know that everything I'm
showing you in plain text can also be
done in a notebook equally
well so uh navigation bar uh it's
straightforward you can you give it a
title and an author you have pages in
your dashboard and those become pages on
the navigation bar and then if you want
to put some nav buttons to provide
Social Links or even just arbitrary
custom links those are easy to add as
well so that's the navigation
bar um sidebars um we'll get into this
there kind of essential in more
interactive applications and you can
have sidebars so here you know these are
the headings and these are this is a
Jupiter notebook cell basically in plain
Tex so just whenever you see this in
these demos that's a jupyter notebook
cell
um so sidebars you can have inside a
page so in this layout you have a
sidebar with a column next to it um and
that's a that's just like a sidebar that
sits inside a page um but you can also
have a global sidebar where the sidebar
is available across all pages in the
dashboard so if you want to do a global
sidebar you put the sidebar uh attribute
on an H1 and now that'll be Global to
the whole dashboard and you can see
we've got a plot p a data page and a
global sidebar so as I switch Pages the
sidebar will remain in
place more useful for interactive
dashboards but also can be useful for
static dashboards for stuff you want
with the user a clear way optionally so
layout um you couldn't see this that
well in the notebook version but uh
those row headers actually had a a
height attribute on them so when you
define a row or a column you can give it
a height or a width which allows you to
in this case you know like Focus the
user's attention on kind of the main
chart that's the main thing I want you
to be looking at and then and then say
these charts are more more tertiary or
secondary um so here you just use the
height attribute to drive
that um and this now going back to kind
of the initial set of examples we used
you can see how that's used here this
has three rows and You Know Each of
which is sort of has one of them has
three items one two and one just a
single in the row but this is a row
oriented layout for the dashboard um you
can so that's the default um you can
also switch the orientation to columns
and in some cases that's uh that's more
desirable or useful uh and then with
columns you you can set a width so
here's an example of like you've got one
chart or whatever this is it could be
just like a data table or anything um
here it's taking 60% and then my other
charts are here uh and that kind of of I
don't know if I showed this example
before I don't think I did but this is a
column oriented dashboard layout where
I've actually put the value boxes here
and I've got columns one of which is has
a tab set inside it so it depends on
what you're trying to present how you're
trying to present it how dense the
information is how much you want to
focus on one versus many charts but rows
and columns are very flexible and they
can Nest arbitrarily inside themselves
as as can tab sets uh so you can kind of
you can pretty much build any layout
that you can
imagine uh and specifically tab sets you
just say this row rather than have two
side by-side charts I would like this
row to be organized as a tab set and now
you can see here instead of having two
separate boxes for chart two and chart
three it's just going to make tabs for
them uh and in that case you you're
going to want to put a t you don't
you're not required to put titles on
cells normally you can have them be
Untitled to show the the visual ization
but in this case you want to put a title
so the tab as a title so you do that by
adding This Ti title option
comment um and this is an example again
I think we saw this one earlier here's
here's the use of tab sets inside inside
dashboard so that's pretty
straightforward okay so talk a little
bit about some of the specific data that
you'll put in a dashboard um plotly is
has a lot of reasons why um it's an
excellent library for dashboards
um one reason is that uh dashboards as a
you don't have no idea what the size of
the browser is going to be including it
could be a mobile browser and you really
want the plots to size themselves
intelligently to the space that they're
painted in plotly does a very very good
job at that so whatever space is in it
will automatically relay it out um I
think boate does a pretty good job with
this too um so that's one advantage of
plotly is that you get this Dynamic
sizing Behavior and the other nice thing
this also applies to tooke is um that
plotly can give you interactive features
even though you don't have a back end um
you could also uh use other Jupiter
widgets any Jupiter widget so in this
case I'll show you iPie leaflet here you
can see that that this is going to look
better if I can full bleed to the edges
of the card not have padding around it
so I set set the padding option to zero
and you can use um Regular static like
matte plut Li Seaborn graphics you have
to when you do that you have to pay a
little more attention to the size like
okay this plot's going to be a little
wider than tall so maybe I want to
actually emit it that way um they'll get
sized automatically but it's not as
fluid as the JavaScript based plotting
Library so there pros and cons one of
the negatives of JavaScript based
libraries is they embed all the data in
the web page so if you have a lot of
data you really kind of have no choice
but to use like a regular static uh
static plot
Library uh for tables you you can use
the tabulate package to create a
markdown table from many many types of
uh python data frame uh M Matrix many
data structures are supported by
tabulate and that just creates a
markdown table um you can also use the
it tables package which gives you a uh
you know a sortable filterable view of
data so both are both are
supported um value boxes we showed a
little bit the value box we basically
right now now we we we'll actually
eventually have a package that you can
just call functions to make the value
boxes for now it's a little bit of a
workaround we just print a dict with the
value box attributes from the cell and
um you'll see what it looks like here
but I wanted to focus you in on the fact
that um these values can be dynamic so
in this case like depending on the
direct you know depending on the value
the icon would change or the color would
change so in this case we're saying you
know the price is up so we're going to
put an up Arrow and Green but you can
imagine it was other otherwise you can
use a different color so that that's a
dimension of value boxes that are also
Dynamic and then I think very
importantly um you can include arbitrary
text content in dashboards uh here you
can see I've basically just put a this
is the the plain text version of just
like a markdown cell so in a notebook I
would just make a markdown cell and it
would it would work just this way in
plain text you delineate uh the content
with this card div and then um you know
it just it just goes in alongside your
plot so it's very easy to add narrative
uh and Analysis and things like that uh
in alongside visualizations and
tables um and the last piece of sort of
dashboard components is all uh cards
have this expand Icon by default so you
know some of these visualizations can
get kind of small so when the user user
hovers their Mouse over the card they
can expand it in this case it goes like
full screen and they can see like a more
more zoomed in view of the plot you can
turn that off if you want but it's on
it's on by default okay so that's kind
of like Whirlwind grand tour of all the
different kind of ways you can the
different components of dashboards how
you present data how it kind of maps to
markdown headers and notebook cells um I
want to talk a little bit about
different ways to deploy dashboards um
the most of what I've shown you right
now so far are just static HTML pages so
they actually can be deployed to any web
server web host they don't require a
python processor server so they're very
lightweight very scalable um so that's
the basic kind of static dashboard and
you can imagine like if the underlying
data won't ever change I have a
dashboard about like the 2016 election
it's the data is not going to change I
don't need to keep rendering it it's
just the election uh or whatever or you
know the
q1 whatever just something that's
historical data that's not going to
change a single static rendering of it
can be fine um but then obviously you
want to in some cases have scheduled
dashboards so you know use a Chron job
or any other kind of uh job manager to
basically say I want to render my
dashboard every day or every every hour
or whatever whatever is
appropriate um you can also have a
parameterized dashboards so and I'll
show an example of that in just a minute
so you can say well you know the
dashboard
um will depending on the parameters it
might it might Target a certain region
or it might Target a certain assumption
and in that case I want to have a
different version of the dashboard so
you can declare parameters in dashboards
and then have those create variants of
the dashboard and that works well with
static both static and scheduled
dashboards and then finally you can have
an interactive dashboard that has a
server backend uh that that uses shiny
which is another open source uh project
from posit uh and I'll describe how to
do that but when you do that it requires
a server for
deployment so I want to uh speak briefly
about the idea of a parameterized
dashboard we use the same kind of uh
technique that paper mill uses to
declare parameters so in paper mill you
basically add a tag to a cell called
parameters and then you declare a bunch
of variables in there and then once
you've done that you can when you render
you can give it you know this param you
can have as many as you want and it'll
vary the dashboard based on uh based on
the parameter so in this case it's this
is a dashboard for a single stock but
you might want to render it for
different stocks and that parameter
allows you to do it so that's
parameterized
dashboards interactive dashboards are a
whole different thing but they're a
really pretty natural extension of all
the stuff I've shown you with static
dashboards again these build on uh the
shiny package which is another python
open source project both Python and R
open source SCE project composit shiny
is kind of its own thing it's got its
own whole application framework and way
of doing things in this case we're just
we're just going to sort of embed shiny
components inside a Cordo inside a Cordo
dashboard all
right sorry this thing's not on there we
go all right so this is like a super
simple shiny uh uh dashboard hello shiny
so you can see it on the right it's just
a single plot and it's got three inputs
and I'll walk you through what the code
looks like for this you can see we're
still using markdown headings just all
the same kind of dashboard syntax that
we talked about but we've added this
server shiny to indicate this this
dashboard should have a back end um
first I'm going to Define call a bunch
of functions from the shiny package to
Define three inputs and those map here
to you know variable distribution and
this whether to show rug marks and those
are just functions that say here's a
variable I'm declaring it here's the
label I want to have for and here's the
choices to offer so that's really
straightforward we put those in the
sidebar and then over here we Define a
function that creates a plot uh this
uses a python decorator you you'll see
in China there's a bunch of
decorators uh render decorators and
what's noteworthy about here is you'll
see that nowhere in this file do we
actually call this function using The
Decorator basically instruct shiny
please call this function whenever any
of the inputs that are referenced by it
change so shiny will automatically call
this function when it needs to and you
can see in this line here we're actually
referencing those inputs defined above
so whenever you see these render uh kind
of decorators you're just saying like
set this up to be called whenever things
that it depends on change so that's like
a super simple uh glow shiny um you can
do quite a bit more sophisticated uh
shiny dashboards uh this one steps up a
little bit it's still pretty simple it's
got a couple Pages it's got more inputs
but all of a stuff I showed you with
value boxes and tab sets and rows and
columns and tables you can all you can
all do that interactively with with
shiny components as well um in terms of
deploying these things there are quite a
few different ways to do that uh and
they're basically they're standard uh
asgi python apps so you don't need
anything special per se to deploy them
you can just call shiny run and as long
as your server environment supports
websockets and sticky sessions then you
can serve it um that said there are some
easier ways to deploy that take care of
some of the the networking and uh and
scaling and uh things like that um so
there's a couple cloud services that
support shiny uh deployment shiny apps
iio that's one that posit has created
and then hugging face also supports
shiny apps uh and then if you're running
your own server we have an open source
server that lets you deploy shiny apps
and we also have um a commercial product
that lets you deploy shiny apps and then
of course as I said you can completely
roll your own um you don't need to use
any of these products they just kind of
make some some things easier so I I did
um earlier say that whenever you use
shiny components you're going to need a
server that's not entirely true we
actually have a way to deploy these
dashboards that use shiny completely
serverless using pide um and so we
actually have an example up on our site
to show you you can use Python use you
know map live and pandis and everything
and actually have it all run inside the
web browser um and then then then
there's no server in that case and so
this retirement simulation example we
have uh shows you how to do that and
this is this is the app it's just pretty
simple it's just got two scenarios and
you can you change them and it reruns
the simulation but this is all running
all running inside the browser it's
using map plot live and everything all
in the browser so that is there is a
serverless option that you
have
all right so that is now kind of
completed telling you all about
dashboards I wanted to conclude by
giving a little bit of insight into
posit company what our philosophy is and
kind of what the work we've done so far
in in the python
space so we were founded 14 years ago uh
as our studio and our mission was then
and now and will be to create open
source software for data science we're
actually organized as a public benefit
the corporation which means a bunch of
things but mostly it means that our
mission is encoded into our corporate
charter our uh officers and directors
actually have a fiduciary duty to pursue
this Mission and that when we make
decisions that traditional corporations
like a normal C corporation really needs
to narrowly consider the interest of the
shareholders as kind of the the only
thing that really ultimately matters and
public benefit corporations can be much
more diverse they have their mission
they have the community they have the
community they have their employees they
have the shareholders they sort of look
at all the stakeholders so that's our
approach kind of at a corporate level
and we've actually gone to pretty
significant lengths to try to make sure
that never changes so we are an
independent company and we are committed
to not ever selling the company and not
going public so we are always going to
be an independent and private company to
that end we have control of the company
entirely inside so outside investors do
not have a way to force us to do
anything thing all of the main control
within people inside the
company um I think that allows us to um
have an imperative that isn't growth at
all cost which is I think the imperative
of most startup companies even most big
public companies but try to build
something that's sustainable and
building open source software and and
providing a trustworthy foundation for
users of Open Source software for for a
long long time 100 years might be a
little little extreme but uh as long as
possible uh 100 years as
inspirationally um and as I said we want
to be durable we want to be trustworthy
we want you to understand that that our
core motivation is to is to create open
source software and make it incredible
and easy to use and and let people use
code to do data science um and make it
all open uh and that's that's kind of
our bottom
line um so we've begun recently actually
probably starting about 3 years ago to
to work on a lot more python open source
projects so CTO we heard all about today
there's a separate project called CTO do
that helps with creating doc package
documentation for python packages we've
seen a bunch of packages are using it
now Ibis just switched over to using PTO
doc um we've also got shiny which you
heard about today so shiny Works inside
Porto but also kind of or Standalone and
we have some other packages you may not
have heard of um V for kind of model Ops
subba is a data manipulation library and
plot N is a is a data bu Library so
we've got lots of projects we we've got
a lot of investment in these projects
and we'll have more projects over time
um we're also very much involved with
num focus and we're working closely with
the um the Jupiter Community on some
standards for uh scientific notebook
publishing and an effort called
notebooks now so we're doing a lot with
python we're going to do a lot more in
the future and we invite kind of all of
you to to help us figure out um you know
what the right right tools are what the
right path is what things should work
well together um and I'm really excited
to get going on this um so if you want
to learn more about what I showed you
today it's important to note that this
dashboard feature is in the pre-release
of Cordo it is not in the main 1.3 which
is our current production release it's
in the pre-release
so if you go to the docs on dashboards
it's going to say this over and over
again like don't remember get the
pre-release um but this is just another
reminder you can go directly to it you
can pip install it from our G
repo um here's ways to get more info
about PTO itself and dashboards a little
more about shiny and then if you want
these slides that's the EUR off of the
slides so that I'd love to answer any
questions people
[Applause]
[Music]
have
[Applause]
collor
Rel tax hopefully see some consolidation
yeah yes yeah so the question is there's
another project that's similar to Cordo
called M
MJS um and we are working with them on
the notebooks now one of the ideas was
that we recognize that like there's not
going to just be like one markdown
system for Jupiter for all time so we
didn't want to like make this the
standard for scientific Publications as
like one open source project so we
worked with them to kind of create an
intermediate format that basically
multiple projects can Target and so by
the time you get to that format there's
like no vestiges of the of quo or missed
so that was an effort to just make sure
that the standard was like Beyond any
given project um and M is a similar
project they're i' would say they're a
little more focused on scientific
manuscripts and websites they're they're
not quite as Broad in the different
things they're going after um they do
have a little different syntax we're
actually working with them to try to
like can we get the citation syntax to
be the same could get the div syntax to
be the same but they they do have
different lineages and so they're not
identical any other
questions thank you for the present
present ation that was awesome um the
pite uh version that we the P scripts is
the dashboard limited to what package
liaries are available or does s to
overcome that no it's whatever works in
pii and so you have to test it so we
have you sort of export it to a web page
and then you kind of load it up in your
browser and say did you know did all did
all the libraries
work yes over there uh can you tell a
little bit more about the notebooks now
is there a website for it or how do we
app yep so if you Google for notebooks
now you'll find like a kind of the a
project page for it but if you want to
find out like the specific stuff that
we've done for it if you Google for um
quto manuscripts that's kind of the
feature that we have that integrates
with notebooks now um Googling is
pulling up an agu yeah so that's
notebooks now that's agu that's what it
is but if you want to I don't know how
like that website is not not super live
so if you want to find like the the more
specific stuff if you go to if you just
Google quto
manuscripts and or you could you could
Google like missed notebooks now and
then you'd find like the
specific uh yeah the agu has like
there's a GitHub Organization for it I I
forget what the URL is
but okay we'll take one more
question
any releas yeah this uh this will be
final I'd say by pretty solidly by like
1 of February like like we have there's
some things we need that there's some
reasons we have to make sure it ships by
about that time so it's you know it's um
it's you know a lot of people run the
pre-release I I wouldn't discourage you
at all from using it it's it's it's
quite solid um but the final release
will probably be more like more like
early February and and really not not
definitely be out
there great okay perfect thank you J for
such an awesome
presentation